hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
hi I'm John Humphrey hope you guys had a
good Memorial Day over in India and UK
the States
I hope it was boring for you we're gonna
watch the latest trailer for Annabelle
comes home I'm excited for the most part
I suppose before we go into that I want
to thank everyone who's downloaded and
follow us on the Stardust app over there
we do 30 second reaction reviews for
films TV shows and or trailers you've
heard us mention this [ __ ] countless
times there's a reason why because we're
[ __ ] all over that app every single
day it's free to download it who likes
free [ __ ] this guy likes free [ __ ]
hopefully I don't get so much yellow
dollar bill signs all the [ __ ] mentions
[Music]
Adam the rain
[Music]
dad work Babel is contained yeah we'll
be back early tomorrow morning
don't your parents keep any creepy stuff
around you keep it all locked away in a
room it's not good for anyone to go in
there chosen right away leave a point
over the eyes of the Dead so you take
their cells
that's gonna come in
it's the coins from the eyes
[Music]
yeah
something is happening inside your house
and I'm not really sure that any part
give me some nipple chills the curse of
my yoga
yeah yeah this all the same world you
know eventually it's gonna be hard to
attend this movie that week I have jury
duty
oh let's talk about that well you talk
about jury duty game shows I'm probably
going to get chosen I try to get
selected to beyond yeah nothing gives me
a greater sense of purpose
what exactly is making this not
conjuring three and Annabelle three like
what it it seems like this could also
work if this was conjuring three
subtitle Annabelle comes home yeah
definitely the convergence of two
corners of this franchise for for sure
it's just like Eden Lorraine or like the
you literally are the parents who are
outlaws so buddy the baby see they're
just here over the phone or something
and is this like an in-between and I I'm
not gonna lie I am NOT the guy who
revisits the conjuring franchise i watch
them all once and I gotta move on
because I thought they already put
Annabelle in the in the case yeah in the
first movie and I know there was some
shenanigans that went down and they had
a little tease at the end close and
closing up on her face but she didn't
come back to play in part two of the
conjuring so is this like an in-between
conjuring is this is this in that little
time gap when I have brought Annabelle
home and some [ __ ] went down that we
didn't know about but isn't the daughter
a little older now I feel like this is
the franchise
going off-road and like I don't know if
this pertains to any purportedly true
period of their history and from what
I've been told the approach they're
taking with this movie which you know it
comes across in this trailers they're
going for night if the museum meets the
conjuring or it's like everything in
their room of haunted and cursed objects
is going to come into play at some point
that's why it feels more like a
conjuring three to me the thing is to me
I mean you know the conjuring movies at
least the first two or the main two
flagship films have at least the conceit
of being based on something kind of real
whereas this does not give me that sense
at all given the preface hey so a
conjuring trailer I mean you know yeah
they got throwback music and then they
let a scene sort of play out sort of
although in this trailer it definitely
felt cut down whereas like if you go
back and look at the clap game from the
first conjuring trailer like that seemed
to breathe a little bit you know well I
mean I heard liar onna does the same
thing and with the other trailer did it
I heard that's connected to the
conjuring verse actually yeah and you
know that one moment with the setup of
the coin eyes and that comes into play I
didn't actually see that specific jump
scare coming the way it occurred I
thought it was neatly done I like the
the funhouse element and the spookiness
of the designs looks very appealing to
me the cinematography looks cool all the
technical stuff looks really
well-executed this does look like a
really the most generic of the generic
of the horror that you could imagine
with this franchise you know it's
whereas and I don't know if for all I
know this could surprise me because of
the writer who's helming this who worked
on the previous contouring films and I
forget the specific ones he worked on
but he's written most yeah and I did one
of the animal wants to it's I imagine
you'd want to bring a different flavor
and perhaps have even kind of a cool
twist ending to this which is something
I you know I always look forward to is
their their their unique hooks at the
end their unique twists especially with
their spin-off movies about the none had
a cool tie in at the end I thought
Annabel creation had a cool tie in at
the end and I imagine there's gonna be
another really cool one I wonder if the
decision to bring in Ed and Lorraine
Warren was purely storytelling
standpoint or was it the fact that I
think creation did well but not as well
as the first Annabel movie even though
it got better reception overall from
audiences and critics this is one of
those big maybes for me where the
conjuring franchise is one that I
generally like although it has become a
very hit-or-miss thing for me and I've
sort of come to only trust the ones that
are called the conjuring and the rest
are sort of like it could be good and
this is one of those things where I feel
like we are at a saturation for this
type of movie and this type of trailer
so there are moments that I'm just like
okay yeah we're gonna do a prolonged
scare moment where's the jump coming
from which of the items are they going
to cleverly play upon and so I hope this
movie finds a way to maintain a
freshness I do like that the tone to me
comes across as though I associate the
conjuring films with being a bit more
they're still wild but more subdued than
like an insidious whereas this feels
like it is bringing in some of that
craziness from an insidious type movie
which is kind of exciting to me Gary
Doberman I'm interested to see what he
does behind the camera because like I
really like some of the movies he's
written for this franchise I feel like
some of them are really really under
written so I feel like he's got the
chops and he also wrote it so like I
feel like he knows his horror pretty
well in these days he's certainly
getting a lot of work in it so I'm
excited to see what he does and there's
a lot of dumb teen girl designs I mean
the first trailer we laughed at one
moment that she has mushy says that
touched everything free and then I was
saw it in the trend the theaters for
watch Pet Sematary everyone in the
theater laughs and a good and then hear
the way they cut it yeah we shouldn't go
when they're literally illegal so
if they go with like a fun
tongue-in-cheek almost like some kind of
fund smiling behind the camera tone
maybe that could work you know but yeah
right now there have been these like
weird and intentionally silly aspects to
house trailers that I'm not super
psyched about well guys are you excited
for Annabelle comes home I bet you are
you throwing Warner Brothers your money
just get your and Warner Brothers money
before we wrap this video up I want to
give a page from the day shout to a man
named Daniel Gallagher Daniel my friend
you got to give me more info to work off
of I'm running out of nuance for your
shout outs I keep pointing out you're
Scottish
I keep pointing out your old pharmacy
background and then I talked about your
twitter and had people you know shot you
out over there but dude I am running low
on unique things about your personal
life that's happened - can you give me
some list of like your traumatic
backgrounds that you have a drug
addiction or did you go to jail for
anything have you been fired for
anything for any purpose what was the V
cheated on anyone I need some real nitty
gritty stuff that would really be
helpful for your next shoutout so this
this shoutout is meant to inspire you to
give me more information thanks dude
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the reject nation if you like this video
hit the like button and you know who do
you want to see Annabelle crossover with
bye